MORNING AND WHAT EVERYONE THANK
YOU FOR JOINING US LET ME
REMIND EVERYONE OF THE GROUND
WAS FOR TODAY'S HEARING. AS YOU
KNOW DO THE COVER NINETEEN WE
HAVE LIMITED SPACE AVAILABLE IN
THIS ROOM IN THE CAPITOL.
PLEASE BE MINDFUL OF THE MASS
REQUIREMENT WHILE YOU'RE HERE
AND MAINTAIN PHYSICAL
DISTANCING. MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC CAN PARTICIPATE IN
TODAY'S HEARING BY CALLING.
977-692-8957 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS ONE THREE ONE. FIVE
FOUR THREE SEVEN YOU CAN ALSO
VISIT THE SOMEBODY'S COMMITTEES
WEBSITE AT A. E. M. DOT
ASSEMBLY DOT CA DOT GOV.
ASSEMBLY HOUSE RULES TO ENSURE
WE MAINTAIN ORDER AND RUN INTO
FISHING HEARING WE SEEK TO
PROTECT THE RIGHTS OF ALL WHO
PARTICIPATE IN THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. SO WE CAN HAVE
EFFECTIVE DELIBERATION AND
DECISION ON THE CRITICAL ISSUES
FACING CALIFORNIA. IN ORDER
FACILITATE THESE GOALS WILL NOT
PERMIT CONDUCT THAT DISRUPTS
DISTURBS OR OTHERWISE IMPEDE
TODAY'S ORDERLY CONDUCT OF THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCEEDINGS. SO
WITH THAT IN THE ABSENCE OF A
QUORUM-I WILL GO AHEAD AND
START. I KNOW WE DO HAVE A
SENATORS HERE ALREADY. SO
CENTER GREATER JOY LIKE TO
PRESENT.
WHAT ARE THE NUMBERS.
ARE YOU SHOULD BE WORKING IT'S
WITH WORKING DOESN'T YEAH OKAY
GOOD MORNING- MEMBERS THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT
S. B. SEVEN EIGHTY FOUR TODAY.
THIS BILL AND THAT NOT
ORGANIZATION THAT PROVIDE
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES UNDER
CONTRACT WITH THE STATE HAVE
THE SAME FLEXIBILITY DURING A
DECLARED STATE OF EMERGENCY AS
THE STATE'S OWN DEPARTMENTS AND
WORKFORCE. NON-PROFIT OR- AS
YOU ALL DELAY AS SIR TO
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS ON BEHALF
OF AND FUNDED BY THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AS THE COVERT
NINETEEN. DEMONSTRATED MANY
IMPORTANT NONPROFIT PROGRAMS
CAN BE DISRUPTED BY DISASTERS
OR OTHER EMERGENCY. THIS CAN
IMPACT THE NONPROFIT'S ABILITY
TO SERVE ITS COMMUNITY BY
LIMITING ITS PROGRAMS AND ITS
CASH FLOW. OR TO DO A SURVEY
AND THIS IS NOTED IN YOUR
ANALYSIS A GREAT ANALYSIS THANK
YOU THE STAFF FOR THAT- IT. TO
A SURVEY. BY NONPROFITS. 86% OF
NONPROFIT SURVEYED REPORTED
NEEDING CHANGES TO THEIR
CONTRACT. DELIVERABLE
REQUIREMENTS. MORE THAN TWO
THIRDS 68% REPORTED IN
CONSISTENT GUIDELINES FROM
DIFFERENT DEPARTMENTS OR LEVELS
OF GOVERNMENT. 69% REPORTED
NEEDING TO MOVE MONEY FROM ONE
BUDGET ITEM TO ANOTHER WITHOUT
GOING THROUGH THE LENT THE-
BUDGET MODIFICATION PROCESS.
RECOGNIZING THAT NONPROFITS.
ARE THE BACKBONE OF THE SERVICE
OF PLY CHIANG AND RESTRICTING
DOWN PERMANENTLY WITHOUT
CONTINUED SUPPORT SEVERAL
COUNTIES IMPLEMENTED POLICIES
TO GRANT THEIR NONPROFIT
PARTNERS FLEXIBILITY THIS
ALLOWED THEM TO ALTER THE TERMS
OF THEIR CONTRACT AS LONG AS
THIS IS IMPORTANT AS LONG AS
THE GOALS OF THE CONTRACT WE'RE
STILL MATT. SB SEVEN EIGHTY
FOUR WOULD ENSURE THAT SIMILAR
FLEXIBILITY IS EMBEDDED INTO
THE STATE'S CONTRACTS THIS BILL
IS SUPPORTED BY THREE HUNDRED
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS FROM
ACROSS THE STATE AND WITH ME TO
TESTIFY TODAY MISTER CHAIRMAN
OUR DOCTOR INAS THROUGH ITS
HOUSTON WHO IS VICE PRESIDENT
OF SPECIAL PROGRAMS AND CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT AT EL CONCILIO AND
JENNIFER PARK DIETZ EXECUTOR
ACCURATE PEOPLE ASSISTING THE
HOMELESS WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
TODAY. THANK YOU CENTER I
BELIEVE WE HAVE THE WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT OPERATOR DO WE HAVE-
THE WITNESSES ON THE LINE.
THANK YOU MEDICARE WE DO NOT
HAVE ALL THE WORK WE GET ON THE
PHONE. BUT WE DO HAVE JENNIFER
HEARTBEAT. WERE THOSE ONES
ENERGY HUNDREDS OF YES IF YES I
GO AHEAD AND KEEP THEM. A LOT
OF OTHER THINGS GO AHEAD AND- I
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND GOODBYE
COMMITTEE. MY NAME JENNIFER
HART AND I AM THE DRIVE OF OR
PEOPLE AT THE IN THE HOME. I OF
THE LARGEST HOME SERVICE. AND
CAL. BUT I'M NOT THE THOUSAND
CATHOLIC. WE THIRD NEARLY
TWENTY. OF THE STATE POPULATION.
COMPARTMENT AT THE END
HOMELESSNESS FOR IN THE-
FAMILIES CAN. AND WE CA THAT
BY PROVIDE BERMAN SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING INTERM. AND ARRAY OF.
SERVICES. WE APPRECIATE SENATOR
HER OFF AT THE SEVEN EIGHTY
WITH IS KNOWLEDGE OF THE NEED
FOR CON LIKE. TO STATE
EMERGENCIES FOR NON WORK. LIKE
OUR SHE THAT PROVIDE DIRECT
UNDER. WITH AT. IT IS
ESPECIALLY TRUE WHEN WE'RE
WORKING WITH OUR AND HELP ME
BIRTH. OUR ABILITY TO
EFFECTIVELY REACH COMMUNICATE
AND THIRD BAND WITH MADE
EXPONENTIALLY HARDER DUE TO THE
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY. WERE
FIRMLY COMMITTED TO LIVING UP
TO EXPECTATIONS LAID OUT AND
ALL OF OUR CONTRACT BUT IN A
TRULY UNANTICIPATED MOMENT LIKE
THAT GREATER FLEXIBILITY WITH
FACEBOOK **** AND LIVE. BEING
ABLE TO FOCUS ON OUR MISSION
ESPECIALLY DURING A CRISIS.
IT'S PIVOTAL TO OUR LONG TERM
SUCCESS. THANK YOU FOR
CONSIDERING SB SEVEN EIGHTY
FOUR WE URGE YOU TO SUPPORT
THANK THEM FOR BUT VERY
IMPORTANT THAT ALL. THANK YOU
WAS THERE ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT VIA PHONE. OPERATORS
ARE ANYONE ELSE OR JUST THE ONE.
WHEN WE DO NOT HAVE A WHOLE DAY.
OKAY THAT'S FINE WITH THAT
SINCE WE DO HAVE A QUORUM
SECTOR LET'S DOUBLE CHECK ONCE
BEFORE MOVE ON. RODRIGUEZ HERE.
RODRIGUEZ HERE THEY ARE STILL
CERTO ABSENT AGAR CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY HERE CALDERON
CALDERON ABSENT GALLAGHER HERE
GALLAGHER HERE GREAT GREAT
ABSENT WARD YOUR WORK HERE IF
THE COURT OKAY WITH THAT. SO WE
HAVE A MO AND A SECOND. MOTION
BURGLAR CURRY SEKHEMRE TO WAR.
SO WITH THAT I WILL GO ON TO
ANY OPPOSITION. IS THERE A
OPERATORS ARE ANY OPPOSITION ON
THE LINE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF S. B. ONE MOMENT SEVEN
EIGHTY SEVEN EIGHTY FOUR. SEVEN
EIGHTY FOUR SORRY IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB
SEVEN EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE PRESS
ONE TO ZERO FOR IT WILL PROVIDE
YOU WITH YOUR LINE NUMBER AND
PUT YOU BACK INTO Q. ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB. SEVEN EIGHTY
FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO NOW.
MOMENT IS THE CHAIR. LINE
NUMBER TEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HOLIDAYS I
WENT IT COULD AFFECT THE
SUPPORT POSITION I WILL BRING
MYSELF. THANK ONE MOMENT IN
SOME OF THE CHALLENGES GO BACK-
I MISUNDERSTOOD YOU I THOUGHT
WE WERE STILL LOOKING FOR JOSE
RODRIGUEZ SO IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN
EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE
TWO ZERO IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB. SEVEN EIGHTY
FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO NOW.
THAT'S LINE NUMBER TWELVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES THIS IS LUCY SALCEDO CARTER
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF NONPROFIT IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU A LINE NUMBER TEN THE LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
STOCK HIT OFF ON BEHALF OF THE
NATIONAL ACTION COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. AND AT THIS
TIME OF THE CARE WE HAVE NO ONE
ELSE IN SUPPORT. SO LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB SEVEN
EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE TO
ZERO. IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION- SB SEVEN EIGHTY
FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
THERE ARE NOW. AT THIS TIME
MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE NO ONE IN
Q. OKAY THANK YOU ALSO GO HERE
TO THE- COMMITTEE ROOM ANYBODY
HERE AND SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
FOR SB SEVEN EIGHTY FOUR.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE. LET'S
BRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OUR DIRECTORY-
SENATOR THANK YOU SO MUCH THIS
IS A REALLY IMPORTANT BILL- AS
YOU KNOW I'VE HAD FIRES FOR SIX
YEARS SOLID IN MY DISTRICT
EVERY COUNTING ON FIRE THE
NONPROFIT TO THE GLUE THAT
KEEPS A LOT OF THIS TOGETHER.
AND I DON'T WANT TO HINDER THEM
FROM BEING AND HAVING THE
FLEXIBILITY ON BE ABLE TO MOVE
MONEY OR DOING WHATEVER THEY
NEED TO DO TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY- ARE OBLIGED TO WHAT WE
NEED FOR OUR CONSTITUENTS SO
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BRINGING
AFFORD. AND BEING SO THOUGHTFUL
NOT TO FORGET THESE PEOPLE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ANY OTHER.
COMMENTS SENATE HEARING ON.
THANK YOU CENTER GLAZER THERE
IS A MOTION A SECOND WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK YOU CHAIR
AT. THAT EIGHTY THOUSAND
NONPROFITS IN CALIFORNIA AND
BOY DID THEY STAND UP- IN THE
LAST FIFTEEN MONTHS OF THE MOST
DIFFICULT CIRCUMSTANCES AND- I
KNOW THERE'S GREAT APPRECIATION
FOR EACH OF YOU FOR. THOSE THAT
HAVE HELPED YOUR COMMUNITY AND
SO MANY SIGNIFICANT WAYS. NO
ONE LIKES TO THINK ABOUT THE
NEXT EMERGENCY. WE CERTAINLY
HOPE THAT WE WON'T FACE ONE
LIKE WE HAVE EXPERIENCED- THIS
PAST YEAR BUT- WE HAVE TO
ANTICIPATE THAT. AND WE HAVE TO
SHOW LEADERSHIP TO TRY TO
ADJUST TO IT AND LEARN FROM
WHAT WE'VE JUST GONE THROUGH IN
THIS BILL TRIES TO DO THAT AND
WITHOUT RESPECTFULLY
ASTRONOMICAL. THANK ROOM AND
HOW DO. SUPPORT YOUR BILL. 101%
I DO HAVE I RECALL SO WE DO
HAVE MOTION THE SECOND- DO
PASSED APPROPRIATIONS SO
SECRETARY LIKE CALDERON.
SPECIALIST YOU PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS RODRIGUEZ HI
RODRIGUEZ HI THERE ARE STILL.
SIR DODD SAID AGUIAR-CURRY. I
GOT CURRY I CALDERON- CALDERON
HI GALLAGHER. ALL I GREAT BUT
GREAT I WORK. FORD FIVE SIX IS
THE BUILD UP THE MOTION
SOMETHING CENTER THANK YOU CARE
SO WITH THAT- COMMITTEE MEMBERS
GO BACK TO THE- ADAMS ON
CONSENT THERE ARE THREE BILLS
ON CONSENT. A. B. FIFTEEN SIXTY
FIVE SB EIGHT SIXTEEN AND S. B.
EIGHT ONE SEVEN SECRETARY TECH
CALL THE ROLL FOR THE ITEMS ON
CONSENT FIRST WHAT DO WE HAVE A
MOTION AND SECOND FOR THE ITEM
ON CONSENT. MOTION A SECOND BY
SUMMER CURRY SECOND BY MR
GALLAGHER. MOTION FOR SB EIGHT
SIXTEEN IS TO PASS A CONSENT
MOTION FOR SB EIGHT SEVENTEEN
AS YOU PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
WITH RECOMMENDATION TO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR AND THE MOTION
FOR AB FIFTEEN SIXTY FIVE IS
THE PAST TO CONSENT RODRIGUEZ
HI RODRIGUEZ I C. R. DEL.
SECTOR ABSENT AGUIAR-CURRY. I
CALDERON. VETERANS GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER I AGREE. OKAY I'VE
WARD FIVE WARD AT SIX IS. AND
WHAT THE CONSENT IS OUT IN
WITHOUT MEMBERS THAT CONCLUDES
OUR MEETING FOR TODAY THANK YOU.